la región de puno en el sur de Perú está
en el ojo del huracán en menos de 24
horas al menos 18 personas perdieron la
vida en las manifestaciones contra la
presidenta Gina boluarte el gobierno
decretó un toque de queda nocturno de
tres días en este territorio la
inmovilización social obligatoria en
puno por el plazo de tres días desde las
veinte horas hasta las cuatro a la de la
mañana
esto en salvaguarda de la vida de la
integridad y de la libertad de todos los
ciudadanos con nacionales de puno entre
tanto en el congreso el Primer Ministro
Alberto tarro la presentó una votación
sobre el nuevo gabinete pero en la
sesión varios legisladores rechazaron su
discurso de protección del pueblo de su
lado la congresista Ruth Luque presentó
a la fiscalía una denuncia penal contra
la presidenta y su gabinete por
homicidio calificado y lesiones graves
en calidad de autores mediatos en
vísperas de una huelga nacional la
organización de Naciones Unidas llamó a
luz manifestantes a mostrar moderación y
pacifismo e instó a las autoridades
peruanas a respetar los Derechos Humanos
reiteramos nuestro llamamiento a que las
fuerzas de seguridad cumplan las normas
de derechos humanos y garanticen que
sólo se hace uso de la fuerza cuando es
estrictamente necesario y en tal caso
respetando plenamente los principios de
legalidad precaución y proporcionalidad
desde diciembre al menos siete personas
han fallecido en los enfrentamientos
entre policías y manifestantes el
gobierno anunció que este miércoles se
ha decretado un día de duelo nacional